need motivation watch a top 10 with the
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was designed to help
you overcome the number one challenge
that is holding you back a lack of
belief in yourself so get ready for some
boundary-pushing motivation from david
Goggins to give you the motivation
confidence and belief that you need
okay let's tick it off with rule number
one push yourself physically
I think pushing yourself physically is
the number one factor of life that is
the true spot where you can really dive
deep into life's about self-discipline
it is about self-discipline we tend to
do the things that are easy and that is
the it builds no mental toughness if
there's no mental hardening it builds
nothing when you work out working out is
where you can build that the fastest
because it's a constant it gives you
instant feedback is it yeah you may not
lose the weight you want to real fast
but the discipline it takes it transfers
over to all aspects of your life it's
not people man why are you always
working out W stop stop looking at that
way this is the foundation of life when
you look in the mirror every morning we
all look in the mirror to get ready to
go to work to go anywhere the first
thing you see is your reflection if you
don't like what you see in the morning
you lost the war already it's not even
liking what you see it's about looking
at mirror and you may start man I feel
different that reflection maybe that
that reflex is not everything
it's a feeling you're supposed to get so
you have to in life once you leave your
house the war begins in your house you
have some control and that reflects in
that mirror you have to control that
reflection in the mirror that's how you
start your day to leave your house
feeling like okay I can fight I've
established the mentality to fight and
that all that comes from working out
it's not just from you know you can't
find that in the office
rule number two on top your potential
the one thing that only gets me mad
nowadays is that so many people die with
potentially because they think that
someone else is better than them and
they were born you know not with the
greatest tools you don't need you need
the ability to grind your ass into the
fine powder and we need that fine powder
and find a way to build them back up
repeatedly and as possible rule number
three detest mediocrity a lot of us
mediocrity is everywhere right now and
we're all trying to find an easy way out
and we're judging ourselves let's say
there's ten people in this room and
we're all mediocre but I'm the best of
the mediocre people I now think I'm
great I'm great we surround ourselves
around people that make us feel great
they tell us what we want to hear the
second we put ourselves amongst the
uncommon people we don't like that
feeling that challenge didn't feel that
of of that person's making about three
thirty more hey push your stuff we're
going for a run we don't like that
challenge we like that person who says
hey you know I mean I don't feel good
today man and they say oh it's okay
brother take a day off maybe get a pizza
watch the game we like that we we love
that feeling why cuz you understand man
we're good bro we don't want that like
this hey man no bro get your finished on
man it's not being a punk we don't want
in their lives we don't want that person
who's constantly challenging our
weaknesses we want that process
constantly you know macness feel nice
and good insecure nurse that's the
mediocrity of life we want to be the
best amongst the average people people
wonder how do you stay hungry all the
time
because after I accomplished something I
don't sit back like a lot of guys who
graduate buzz graduate this graduate
that they get comfortable they wonder
why I'm getting weak man I don't know I
lost my edge what's going on cuz once
you hit the top of the mountain guess
what happened yeah I'm good I'm good so
you wonder why you're falling down now
because we reach the top of the mountain
you got booked another one that's
mediocrity there's a lot of people in
mediocrity who have a nice resume but
they're one-timers man they hit they hit
a one time deal they busted open got a
lot of
money but they're good you're a mediocre
now man what are you doing today
tomorrow the next day that's why I
listen to theorists I'll listen all that
bullsh
I listen to who's like this man what's
wrong man
tired dude right tired cuz tomorrow I
got to do the fish again man whatever it
is that made me nauseous and sick to my
stomach
it made me hurt there's no ending and
that's the person I listened to that's
the person who's gained knowledge you
gain knowledge do suffering and on the
other end the suffering is a world that
very few very few have ever seen it's a
beautiful world because that's where you
find yourself you don't find yourself in
over here you find yourself on the other
end like the hundred mile race I was
wrong I ran for 24 hours I found myself
on the other end of that race that 19
hours I found wow there's a whole nother
world out here that never even stopped
but the worlds in your mind and that's
with all that mediocrity is about
mediocrity contagious rule number four
stop caring what others think I had to
stop caring what people thought about me
I realized that everybody's that's the
one thing I realized I walked around I
put these people on a pedestal
everybody was better than me so I can't
tell you anything about me cuz you're
gonna judge me and I feel even worse
than what I am what I realized once I
calm my mind down and sat back and
looked at how jacked up this world is
once you realize that you are not alone
everybody that's talking to you about
how jacked up you are only thing they've
done better than you is they've hidden
their depth world better than you have
that's all they've done so once I
realized that if you want to sit back
it's like for instance there's all these
things that are on TV and we have all
these news people judging people who up
in life yeah they made big mistakes but
that person who was judging you on TV I
guaran-damn-tee that that news person
it's am glad that my didn't come out
Butler just a hell out of you I know
that about people so if you were to sit
back and judge how jacked up I was not
messed up my wife was Merry Christmas go
for it have a good time I'm smiling at
you right now knowing you have a secret
that you're not willing to share it
gives you a lot of power when you're
able to go on a podcast that's big and
say hey tell me I'll tell you anything
you want to know kind of no longer care
and that is a lot of power in that to be
able to put your life on a billboard for
the whole world to see and say judge it
man judge it like just me talking about
it makes me feel good also if you want
to have more confidence and self-love
check out my 254 series they are free
the links to join are in a description
below you will never learn from people
if we always tap-dance around the truth
everything I didn't want to do is what
got me to where I'm at today what if I
can become someone that no one thinks I
can be in just that just me talking
about that I have a hair growing up on
my arms rule number five hold yourself
accountable how do you feel about
letting others in on your goals and and
and having like external pressure to
hold you accountable no there's no
external pressure that's best we know
you don't I mean but I think other
people oh yeah oh yeah it no it's
important to have circles it's important
to have like like I talked about man
like like that big rabbit hole of bad
people that you want to get away from
like if you're a drunk
and you want to stop drinking you gotta
get away from those people you want to
build this nucleus around you of people
who are saying it's not okay to sleep in
the day we gotta get after it
hey let me see your journal you're
supposed to be running five miles today
only around three you got to have those
people some people need those people and
it's important but you want to get to
the point in your life it's real
important that you hold yourself
accountable and those people start to
fade away because you now got it you
want to be that person cuz they're not
always gonna be there to hold your hand
rule number six take power over your own
mind your mind has the ultimate tactical
advantage over you it knows what scars
you it it knows your fears you know
insecurities and it protects you which I
talked about the 40% rule in my book the
40% rules all about the brain has the
tactical advantage over you it knows and
it keeps you away from all that that's
why it says don't jump out of airplane
don't go on the ocean with the sharks
it's a protective mechanism don't go
back to the place where your dad beat
the [ __ ] out of you in your mind don't
go back the brain protects you it
protects you so much it doesn't allow
growth so the brain is an amazing thing
but the brain controls you you must
control it you must take power over your
own mind or your mind will guide you
into all the soft speights
soft places that your brain wants to
live in Japan has enough information it
doesn't want to go through that process
of of mind hardening doesn't want to do
that I can't remember what time I got to
be here what time I gotta be there
this is why were to stay I'm peaceful it
wants to stay very peaceful away from
scarring rule number seven figure out
your equation I think we're all an
underdog I think I think the top CEO on
the planet Earth still has that doubt
yeah I don't give a where you're from
Kobe Bryant Michael Jordan the best on
the planet we're all underdogs
whether you're underdog because you put
yourself there to be hungry or yes a
real-life underdog we're all in underdog
and so this this is about the mind and
people discovering the mind their own
mind and one thing I know is we all have
an equation we all have an equation like
you know I'll talk about three point you
know three point one four is PI there's
different equations to figure out
different kind of you know mathematical
problems we as human beings are
mathematical problems I cannot give you
a book for every body in this world
that's what I book even though it's one
book is tailored to the individual it's
not like you do these five steps you're
good no I'm helping you figure out your
equation
because it's different my craze is
different from your equation what's
gonna make you tick what's gonna make
you go the distance what's gonna make
you go to a spot in hell and say I love
this spot it's okay that's what this
book does it helps you figure out your
3.14 helps you figure out your
mathematical equation to say Oh cuz once
you figure out the equation in any math
problem you no longer fail man you got
it figured out rule number eight have a
cookie jar one of the most powerful
weapons I have man's a cookie jar and in
times of need even the hardest person
forgets how badass they are so I've been
through a lot of my life when you're
going through a hard time right now you
forget all the hearts you endured so the
cookie jar is a reminder that oh I can
get through this hard time right now but
you gotta take a second or two to reach
into the mental cookie jar let's say
it's a fortune cookie
but in my mind my mom eats about these
cookies knowing the cookie jar and Oreo
chips or whatever that's why got the
cookie jar from but you got to open up
and say okay man I was in three he'll
weeks and I got through two of them you
know I was in Ranger school I I endured
being called [ __ ] I saw these beatings
III you know my mom soon-to-be husband
got got murdered I saw all these I saw
little kid hair get read about all these
these aren't do it alone I had to remind
myself of the strength and the power
that I have that it's in me it's just a
reminder of how badass you are
in hard times because you know we just
forget that that bad time consumes our
mind and we forget who we are rule
number nine get strategic speaking of
making that list accepting where you're
at so that you can address it in the
book you talk about like what the things
are that you're gonna be doing you're
gonna be putting the list together and
how do people go about using I don't
know if it's the accountability mirror
how do they go about addressing each of
those issues okay
so let's say the first one is you get
the s'more
person in school I had that issue so my
big thing was how I dressed that problem
was I had to sit down each thing that is
wrong with you has to be a focal point
you can't look at this gigantic list
since I got to change all this my god
this is crazy no you take off the first
one I want to be smarter for me that was
my thing I have to I have to become more
intelligent I have such a severe
learning disability I can't retain I had
to now get that one thing and then
strategize in that one problem how can I
do this I'm not gonna learn like you I'm
not gonna learn like anybody else how am
I gonna figure this out so I didn't
figured out okay
where my strengths here where my
weaknesses in learning alright man how
am I gonna do this and I figured out a
way to do it but it's strategizing so
how I learned to this day if I have a
big manual to study I will have to get a
bunch of spiral notebooks from the from
the daggone store and each page I have
to write each page out maybe 10 times so
there was a thousand page dive manual
that I got 18 months before I went to
dive school most people I'm not smart
I'm a ghost if I can pass this test
I realized hang on a second I'm not
smart how can I get past this how can I
get through this obstacle I need to get
I need to acquire this book 18 months in
advance because it could take me 18
months to write down each page over and
over again to then put it to memory so
when the question came up I'd written
that question so many times down in that
and you know on paper that I can recall
okay page 71 was where I remember seeing
this and I can recall it that way and
that's how I did it
so you got to strategize on each problem
you have in life slowly break down that
problem don't think about all the
problems you have just one at a time
and before you know it you fix all these
problems but you cannot focus on all of
them just on the one thing at a time and
you'll number 10 the last one we four
a special bonus clip is do what is right
for watching people fail because bro
straight to hurt your feelings but no
means do I condone bullying I think it's
[ __ ] but we'll set one thing I
believe the truth and tell the truth a
lot of us have loved ones friends people
we see every day we're gaining weight
getting out of shape not going to school
being lazy but we're afraid to tell them
the truth not being bullied but afraid
to tell the truth one that changed my
life
my grandfather he told me you're gonna
know where in your life not being
anything as bad as that hurt me it got
me to put my head on my ass soul orders
take hard not thick-skinned and do
what's right now I've got a special bond
escape from David on how to be a
practitioner that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that is time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go
question number one where do you need to
hold yourself more accountable number
two how can you push yourself physically
every day and number three how can you
do what is right this week a theorist is
a person who reads a book doesn't do it
reads a book learns about something and
then talks about it hmm
a practitioner is myself a practitioner
is a person like me I wanted to be an
expert in the mind a mental toughness
guy beyond mental toughness the only way
to do that in my eyes is to put yourself
in hell mm-hmm put in hell repeatedly
repeatedly put yourself in hell and
study how you process it and that's how
I was able to come up with all these
different ways and all these different
tools to slow the mind down in hell
because the mind just speeds up the mind
wants to get out of the painful
situation the suffering it can't it
can't process it so that's what I
realized by going through all these
different processes of being in hell
weeks
you know it's just bad of them how the
my processes in help
if you want more David Goggins check out
the top 50 rules video I made out of him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there because
everybody else is most people are weak
the whole thing about comfort zones is
if you live in one for too long that
becomes your norm